le vélo dans tous ses états consciente
environnementale envie de garder la
forme ou choix du porte monnaie
la petite reine gagne du terrain en
france il s'est écoulé 2 millions 700
mille vélos en 2018
figure de proue de cette expansion le
vélo électrique le vélo électrique est
ce qu'on vous y avait déjà pensé aussi
heures plus tôt pour quelles raisons
déjà financièrement comme un peu plus
cher et puis moi ça me va bien le vélo
tant que j'ai encore des mollets mais
peut-être dans cinq ou dix ans quand je
pourrai pu faire du vélo normal je
passerai peut-être à l'électrique est ce
que vous y pensez vous oui qui pense
parce que bon je fais depuis longtemps
du vélo normal pour les travailler
notamment et c'est un peu vexant quand
on se donne du mal et qu'on voit et
d'autres passés à fond le vae vélo à
assistance électrique
c'est un peu l'eldorado des marchands de
cycles toutes les boutiques s'y mettent
et on les comprend
en 2018 l'électrique représentait 13%
des ventes mais pour 40% du chiffre
d'affaires
donc voilà les vélos électriques urbains
aujourd'hui c'est en faisant quasiment
90% des vélos de ville qu'on vend et
aujourd'hui ça se développe dans quasi
la totalité des segments des vélos donc
le vtt les vélos de route les vtc un
beau vtt on va commencer dans les 4000
euros et ça peut finir bien au delà des
dix mille euros
le lourd sur la faune cultures et leurs
apps l'état de la chaîne la transmission
le cyclomoteur ça suce qu'un peu plus
vite que d'habitude
faut que tu vérifies s'te plaît s les
choses ont bien changé sur ton vtt il ya
quelques années les puristes voulait pas
en entendre parler
et maintenant la chose qui change tout
j'irai que c'est l'essai on essaie un
vélo et rick avait été électrique qui on
découvre que c'est que du plaisir
on peut aller partout on peut faire des
choses qu'on n'aurait jamais pu faire
avant rouler avec des gendres j'avais pu
rouler avant et ça ouvre tellement plus
de possibilités le coeur du marché de
l'électrique c'est le vélo urbain sow
constructeur bisontin assemble la
majorité de sa production portugal mais
pour les petites séries comme cette
commande pour le réseau de transports de
besançon
cela se passe ici fringues moteur
batterie dérailleur des pièces détachées
venus principalement d'asie car c'est
aujourd'hui la réalité du monde du cycle
qu'il soit électrique ou non la plupart
des fabricants français sont en fait des
assembleurs ce qui fait la différence
la fabrication du cadre aujourd'hui il
ya très peu de marques qui font encore
de a à z leur propre vélo leur propre
soudure on parlait beaucoup à une
certaine époque fans ya quelques années
de quadriller français aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose qui est malheureusement
vais pas dire terminée mais quasiment
dans quelques boîtes en france mais ça
reste pour la majeure partie de
l'approvisionnement
et puis
ça permet de minimiser les coûts
également une croissance insolente de
21% entre les deux derniers exercices
le marché est extrêmement porteur pour
preuve la marque bisontine a créé son
propre réseau de magasins pour ce
fabricant
je le vae est tout simplement dans l'air
du temps ou la suspension vu quelqu'un
qui vaut travail qu 1,5 km 7 kilomètres
à faire ben il se pose la question
d'hier je prends ma voiture et je fais
30 35 minutes tout 45 minutes de
bouchons ou en fait je mets 10 12
minutes pour aller à mon travail
et puis il ya surtout le côté économie
parce que bon havel électrique quand on
a 80 120 euros d'entretien par an c'est
tout le bout du monde
la petite reine synonyme d'économies
certainement mais pour son modèle
électrique compter sur un prix moyen
frisant les 1600 euros de quoi préféré
son traditionnel bicloo pendant encore
quelques temps
[Musique]